This episode is brought to you by Lloyd's business and commercial banking. One of the great things about finance is that it may result in you having to pay tax. And this was a constant grumble in Anglo-Saxon England, which was the most heavily taxed country in the whole of Christendom. And just when the Anglo-Saxons thought it couldn't get any worse, they got conquered by King Canute. And Canute imposed a tax rate that was effectively... 100%. Yeah, well, that was one very big change, Tom, but another tax change is upon us. And this is the advent of making tax digital for income tax. And if you're at all concerned about it, this is where Lloyd's come in, because they're here to help make that change much simpler
本期节目由劳埃德商业银行赞助。金融的一大妙处在于，它可能会让你不得不缴税。这在盎格鲁-撒克逊时期的英格兰是一个持续不断的抱怨，当时它是整个基督教世界中税负最重的国家。而就在盎格鲁-撒克逊人以为情况不会再糟的时候，他们被克努特国王征服了。克努特征收的税率实际上达到了……100%。是的，那确实是一个巨大的变化，汤姆，但另一个税务变革即将来临。这就是针对所得税的“税收数字化”政策。如果你对此有任何担忧，劳埃德银行可以为你提供帮助，因为他们致力于让这一转变变得更加简单。
for you with a useful HMRC-recognised accounting tool that will help you stay in line with all the making tax digital requirements. And the brilliant thing about this is, is that it is free for Lloyd's business account customers. So when it is time to digitize your income tax, you can bank on Lloyd's. Search Lloyd's business accounts to find out more. This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg,
他们为你提供了一款经英国税务海关总署（HMRC）认可的实用会计工具，将帮助你遵守所有税收数字化的要求。最棒的是，对于劳埃德商业账户客户，这款工具是免费的。所以，当需要将你的所得税数字化时，你可以信赖劳埃德银行。搜索“劳埃德商业账户”了解更多信息。今年春天，牛仔服饰迎来了更柔软、更轻盈的升级。隆重推出 Old Navy 的垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤，
a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer. Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool. with a fit that creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price, moment. Old Navy's drapy denim wide leg. Hello, everybody. So that all-time banger was Het Wilhelmus, the national anthem of Holland,
一种随你而动的新版型。它拥有你想要夏天牛仔裤所具备的一切感觉。舒适、透气，且毫不费力地展现酷感。这种版型能营造自然的动感，阔腿设计显得现代而不臃肿。此外，还有那种标志性的“等等，这个价格？”的惊喜时刻。Old Navy 垂坠感阔腿牛仔裤。大家好。刚才那首经典神曲是《威廉颂》，荷兰的国歌，
or as it should be called, the Kingdom of the Netherlands. And if you enjoyed it, if you're a big fan of the Orange National Team, I have tremendous news for you because there are another 14 verses. Now, Tom, obviously this is an anthem close to your heart because of your nominative determinism. We've done three anthems so far. We've done the United States. We have done Great Britain. And we have done Germany.
或者应该称之为荷兰王国。如果你喜欢它，如果你是橙衣军团的忠实粉丝，我有一个天大的好消息要告诉你，因为这首歌还有另外14段歌词。现在，汤姆，显然这首国歌因为你的“名义决定论”而与你心意相通。我们目前已经介绍了三首国歌。我们介绍了美国，我们介绍了英国，我们还介绍了德国。
Very well known, I think, all these three. If you're Dutch, this will be well known too. If you're not Dutch, probably much less well known. But there is a case, isn't there, that of all the world's now, national anthems, even though this was only adopted in 1932, this has the deepest, the longest, the richest history. Yeah, because it has actually been the great anthem of Dutch patriotism for four and a half centuries, so long, long before it became enshrined as the Dutch national anthem. And I will quote from the official website of the Royal House of the Netherlands, which has a very convenient English translation, the melland. the melody of the Wilhelmus originated during the siege of the French city of Chartre in 1568.
我想这三首大家都非常熟悉。如果你是荷兰人，这首歌也会很熟悉。如果你不是荷兰人，可能就没那么出名了。但确实有一种说法，不是吗？在当今世界所有的国歌中，尽管这首歌直到1932年才被正式采用，但它拥有最深厚、最悠久、最丰富的历史。是的，因为它实际上在四个半世纪以来一直是荷兰爱国主义的伟大赞歌，远在它被定为荷兰国歌之前。我引用荷兰王室官方网站的话，上面有非常方便的英文翻译，旋律起源于1568年法国沙特尔城的围城战期间。
So listeners may be wondering why Chartre, who composed it. And we will be coming to this later in the episode. And the website then goes on to say the first known reference to the lyrics dates from 1572. And so there we have it, direct from the Dutch Raw family, the Wilhelmus originated sometime between 1568 and 1572. So that is, you know, compared, say, to God Save the King, that is very, very precise. And those dates, not coincidentally, constitute a key fulcrum point in one of history's absolutely top revolts, the Dutch Revolt. So why is the Dutch Revolt one of history's absolutely top revolts?
所以听众可能想知道为什么是沙特尔，是谁创作的。我们稍后会在节目中讲到。网站接着说，关于歌词的最早记载可以追溯到1572年。所以你看，直接来自荷兰王室的消息，这首歌起源于1568年到1572年之间。所以，比起《天佑国王》，这非常非常精确。而且这些日期并非巧合，它们构成了历史上最伟大的起义之一——荷兰起义的关键转折点。那么，为什么荷兰起义是历史上最伟大的起义之一呢？
Well, I think for a number of reasons. Firstly, it is very seismic in terms of the geopolitics of Europe. It erupts in the 1560s, and it precipitates what will ultimately become an 80-year war between the Dutch rebels and the Spanish, who are the colonial power in the low countries. And this makes it one of the longest and most sustained independent struggles in the whole of European history. And it's an incredible kind of David and Goliath story, because it begins with a rag-bag assortment of pirates, taking on, the professional armies of the greatest empire on the face of the earth at the time. And the consequences of the success of those rebels are still with us today and imprinted on the map of Europe.
嗯，我认为有几个原因。首先，它在欧洲地缘政治方面具有极大的震慑力。它在16世纪60年代爆发，引发了后来荷兰叛军与西班牙之间长达80年的战争，西班牙当时是低地国家的殖民大国。这使它成为整个欧洲历史上最漫长、最持久的独立斗争之一。这是一个不可思议的“大卫与歌利亚”式的故事，因为它始于一群乌合之众的私掠者，挑战当时地球上最伟大帝国的职业军队。而这些叛军成功带来的后果，至今仍影响着我们，并印刻在欧洲的地图上。
So the northern half of the low countries that were ruled by Spain in the 16th century, they won their independence from Spain. And today they constitute the kingdom of the Netherlands and to simplify massively, they're kind of the Protestant half. And the southern half, that remained under the rule of the Spanish royal dynasty, the Habsburgs, and today constitutes the kingdom of the Belgians. And again, to oversimplify, that's kind of vaguely the Catholic half. But the Dutch revolt is not just a European event, is it?
所以，16世纪受西班牙统治的低地国家北部，赢得了从西班牙的独立。今天，它们构成了荷兰王国，简单来说，它们算是新教的一半。而南部则继续处于西班牙王室哈布斯堡王朝的统治下，今天构成了比利时王国。同样，过度简化一下，那大致算是天主教的一半。但荷兰起义不仅仅是一个欧洲事件，对吧？
It's a world event, because the Dutch revolt is you can trace a lineage. And, you know, there are Dutch and indeed American historians who have done this. You can trace the lineage right through from the Dutch revolt of the, the 16th century, the English revolutions of the 17th century to the American Revolution that is celebrating its 250th anniversary this year. Yeah, and the founding fathers certainly believed that they look to the Dutch Revolt as a great source of inspiration. You can see why, because it's a revolt that ends up replacing an imperial monarchy with
这是一个世界性事件，因为你可以追溯荷兰起义的血脉。你知道，确实有荷兰和美国的历史学家做过研究。你可以从16世纪的荷兰起义、17世纪的英国革命，一直追溯到今年庆祝250周年纪念的美国革命。是的，开国元勋们确实认为他们将荷兰起义视为伟大的灵感来源。你可以理解为什么，因为它是一场最终用联邦共和国取代帝国君主制的起义。
a kind of federal republic. And this federal republic, it comes into existence in 1588, and it gives itself the name of the United Provinces of the Netherlands. So you can see why that story would have a resonance with Washington and Hamilton and Jefferson and so on. I don't think it is an exaggeration to see the state that emerges from these rebellious provinces. It becomes the Dutch Republic. And over the course of the 17th century, I think it constitutes one of the great incubators of modernity. So it's the birthplace of modern capitalism. You get, you know, it gives us stock exchanges and deposit banking and futures and options and
这个联邦共和国成立于1588年，自称为“尼德兰联省共和国”。所以你可以看出为什么这个故事会与华盛顿、汉密尔顿、杰斐逊等人产生共鸣。我认为将从这些叛乱省份中崛起的国家称为“荷兰共和国”并不夸张。在17世纪的过程中，我认为它构成了现代性的伟大孵化器之一。它是现代资本主义的发源地。它为我们带来了证券交易所、存款银行、期货和期权，以及
all these kind of various financial gizmos. I don't really know what they mean. I was going to say, we should actually explain about futures and options and how they work. Let's leave that for the rest is money. Okay, fair. I mean, certainly it helps the Dutch of the Republic to become incredibly rich. So considering how small they are relative to the other, you know, to China or India or whatever, I mean, it ends up controlling an insanely large percentage of the total.
所有这些各种各样的金融小玩意。我不太明白它们是什么意思。我正想说，我们应该解释一下期货和期权以及它们是如何运作的。让我们把这个留给《金钱即一切》节目吧。好吧，公平。我的意思是，这确实帮助荷兰共和国变得极其富有。所以考虑到相对于中国或印度等其他国家，他们是多么渺小，我的意思是，它最终控制了全球贸易总额中极其巨大的比例。
total volume of global trade. And the Dutch Republic is per capita by far the richest state on the face of the planet in the 17th century. It's also very modern in the way that it kind of gives birth to kind of traditions of religious toleration that are underground. They're not official, but they're definitely there. And those traditions in turn give birth to kind of religious skepticism, which in turn kind of flourishes in the form of the Enlightenment. it's a very urbanized society. So 60% of the population in Holland live in cities. I mean, that's an enormous amount for the period.
荷兰共和国在17世纪的人均财富是地球上最富有的国家。它在某种程度上催生了地下的宗教宽容传统，这在当时也非常现代。它们不是官方的，但确实存在。而这些传统反过来又催生了宗教怀疑论，进而以启蒙运动的形式蓬勃发展。这是一个高度城市化的社会。荷兰60%的人口居住在城市。我的意思是，对于那个时期来说，这是一个巨大的数字。
And it's a culture, and again, this is appealing, I think, to the American revolutionaries. It's a culture that isn't aristocratic, but very bourgeois. And if you think of the great masterpieces of the Dutch Golden Age, say Vermeer, it's very interior, it's very domestic, it's very comfortable, it's very ordered. So this, the Dutch Republic, the Republic of Vermeer and Rembrandt and the beautiful canals of Amsterdam and all of that, this is the state that emerges from the Dutch revolt. And the man who is most associated with the Dutch revolt is George Washington, you might say, although this man, I think, has his own teeth and doesn't walk around with other people's teeth in his mouth. The sort of the independence hero, he is the man at the center of this song, isn't he? the song is the, I'm tempted to say the Darth Vader, but it's actually the Vada des
这是一种文化，而且我认为这对美国革命者很有吸引力。这是一种非贵族化、非常资产阶级的文化。如果你想到荷兰黄金时代的伟大杰作，比如维米尔的作品，它们非常注重室内、家庭、舒适和秩序。所以，这就是从荷兰起义中崛起的国家——维米尔和伦勃朗的共和国，以及阿姆斯特丹美丽的运河。而与荷兰起义联系最紧密的人，你可以说是乔治·华盛顿，尽管我认为这个人有自己的牙齿，不会嘴里含着别人的牙齿走来走去。他是独立英雄，是这首歌的核心人物，不是吗？这首歌是……我本想说是“达斯·维达”，但实际上是“祖国之父”。
Fadalands, the father of the fatherland. So he is the founding, I mean, he is the founding father, no other way of putting it. And Tom, I know your Dutch is second to none. So would you like to translate that first verse for us? This is, I have to confess, taken from the Dutch royal family's website again. And the words that we heard at the start of this show translated our William of Nassau, skion of a Dutch and ancient line, I dedicate undying faith to this land of mine. A prince I am undaunted of orange ever free to the king of Spain I've granted a lifelong loyalty. And people listening to that if they're not familiar with the Wilhelmers. I mean, they may well have listened to those last two lines and kind of gone, what?
所以他是开国元勋，没有别的说法了。汤姆，我知道你的荷兰语是首屈一指的。你想为我们翻译第一段吗？我必须承认，这又是摘自荷兰王室的网站。我们在节目开头听到的歌词翻译是：拿骚的威廉，荷兰古老血统的后裔，我向我的这片土地奉献永恒的忠诚。我是一位无畏的奥兰治亲王，永远自由，我对西班牙国王保持终身的忠诚。如果听众不熟悉《威廉颂》，听到最后两行可能会感到困惑，会问：什么？
I know. That's absolutely mad. What is happening here? Because just to repeat them, it's to the king of Spain, I've granted a lifelong loyalty. And these must surely be the strangest lines to appear in any national anthem, I would think. Yeah, definitely. What makes it odder is that the guy who is supposedly speaking and who gives his name to the song, William of Nassau, he is the great hero of the Dutch Revolt. He's saying, this is the George Washington of Dutch independence.
我知道。这绝对是疯了。这里发生了什么？因为重复一遍，那是“我对西班牙国王保持终身的忠诚”。我认为这一定是任何国歌中最奇怪的歌词。是的，绝对是。更奇怪的是，那个据说是说话的人，也就是这首歌名字的来源——拿骚的威廉，他是荷兰起义的伟大英雄。他说，这是荷兰独立的乔治·华盛顿。
and he is the man who is leading the fight against the King of Spain. So it's as though the Americans had a national anthem and featured in its first verse George Washington pledging allegiance to George the third. Some people might consider that an improvement, of course. Well, it's a lost opportunity, of course. So what is going on here? Why is William the great hero of the Dutch resistance pledging his loyalty to the King of Spain? And to answer that question, I think we need to look at two different
他是领导反抗西班牙国王的人。所以这就像美国人有一首国歌，第一段却写着乔治·华盛顿向乔治三世宣誓效忠。当然，有些人可能会认为那是一种进步。嗯，当然，那是一个错失的机会。那么这里发生了什么？为什么荷兰抵抗运动的伟大英雄威廉要向西班牙国王宣誓效忠？为了回答这个问题，我认为我们需要从两个不同的
aspects of this story for the background. And the first is the state of the low countries in the mid-16th century when the revolt breaks out. And then secondly, the life and the character of the Prince of Orange, William of Nassau, this great hero of the Dutch Revolt. So let's start with the low countries. So you said before, the low countries cover what are now the Netherlands or Holland and Belgium. There's a little bit of northern. than France, isn't there? Just a little bit of Artouin and Piccaddy. And Luxembourg, I forgot Luxembourg. Oh, that's sad. So there are two main bits, aren't there, of the low countries to worry about. There's basically what becomes Belgium and then what becomes the sort of heartland of Holland. So talk us through these. Back in the mid-16th century, this territory constitutes 17 distinctive provinces and they're divided up, as you said, basically into two halves. And the southern heartland, um, is made up of a province that we've been talking about in the First World War, so Flanders. There's also Brabant to the north. That's where Antwerp is situated.
方面来看这个故事的背景。首先是16世纪中期起义爆发时低地国家的状态。其次是奥兰治亲王、拿骚的威廉，这位荷兰起义伟大英雄的生活和性格。那么让我们从低地国家开始。你之前说过，低地国家涵盖了现在的荷兰和比利时。还有一点点北部，对吧？比如阿图瓦和皮卡第。还有卢森堡，我忘了卢森堡。哦，那太遗憾了。所以低地国家主要有两部分需要关注。基本上是后来成为比利时的部分，以及后来成为荷兰核心地带的部分。那么请给我们介绍一下这些。回到16世纪中期，这片领土由17个独特的省份组成，正如你所说，它们基本上分为两半。南部腹地是由我们在第一次世界大战中谈到的一个省份组成的，即佛兰德斯。北部还有布拉班特。安特卫普就在那里。
And in the 16th century, this is home to very rich and sophisticated cities. So Antwerp is the greatest. You've also got Ghent, you've got Bruges. These are beautiful cities now that you go to on kind of weekend breaks. you know, if you're looking for a place to have a stag do or something. But back then, they were the beating heart of kind of capitalism as it is starting to emerge. And then to the north you have a second heartland. And these are constituted of the largest province is Holland. You also have Zeeland, you have Utrecht.
在16世纪，这里是极其富有和先进城市的所在地。安特卫普是最伟大的。你还有根特、布鲁日。这些现在是你去度周末时会去的漂亮城市。你知道，如果你在寻找一个举办单身派对之类的地方。但在当时，它们是资本主义开始萌芽的跳动心脏。然后向北，你有第二个腹地。这些省份中最大的是荷兰省。你还有泽兰省、乌得勒支省。
And Holland especially is a province that has kind of been redeemed from the seas and the bogs and the lakes. and it is crisscrossed by rivers, by canals, by drainage channels, and all around it are dikes which keep the sea at bay. And an English writer in the 17th century described Holland as the great bog of Europe. Indeed, it is the buttock of the world, full of veins and blood, but no bones in it. and the province of Zealand is even more kind of surrounded by water because it's an archipelago, so a series of islands set in a great estuary that is meeting the North Sea. And on top of that, Holland and Zealand are cut off from the southern provinces by four great rivers,
尤其是荷兰省，它是一种从海洋、沼泽和湖泊中“赎回”的土地。它被河流、运河、排水渠纵横交错，周围都是抵御海水的堤坝。一位17世纪的英国作家将荷兰描述为“欧洲的大沼泽”。确实，它是世界的臀部，充满了静脉和血液，但没有骨头。而泽兰省更是被水包围，因为它是一个群岛，即一系列位于汇入北海的大河口中的岛屿。最重要的是，荷兰和泽兰被四条大河与南部省份隔开，
one of which is the mass that we were talking about in our episode on Germany. And these four rivers all meet in the same delta, and they are surrounded by marshes. So in effect, they constitute a kind of massive moat. So essentially, they are more readily defensible, perhaps, than the southern provinces. And these provinces have their own individual identities, their own system. They have their own institutions, right? Yes, they have their own kind of legal frameworks, their own fiscal arrangements. They often have charters reaching back centuries of which they're inordinately proud.
其中一条就是我们在德国那一集中谈到的马斯河。这四条河流都汇聚在同一个三角洲，周围环绕着沼泽。因此，实际上，它们构成了一种巨大的护城河。所以本质上，它们比南部省份更容易防御。这些省份有各自的身份，各自的制度，对吧？是的，它们有各自的法律框架、财政安排。它们通常拥有可以追溯到几个世纪前的特许状，对此它们感到无比自豪。
And this is especially the case in Flanders and Brabant. the cities there tend to have their own kind of privileges which they guard very, very jealously. And in fact, across the whole of these 17 provinces that constitute the low countries, there are about 700 different legal codes in all. So it is very, very fragmented. Then you also have different languages. So you have French in the southern provinces. You have Dutch in the northern and central provinces. In Frisia, people are speaking Frisians, which is the language closest to English. Some people are speaking German as well. And then this is the mid-16th century, so it's the heyday of the Reformation. And so there are kind of religious tensions and differences
在佛兰德斯和布拉班特尤其如此。那里的城市往往拥有自己的特权，他们对此严加保护。事实上，在构成低地国家的这17个省份中，总共有大约700种不同的法律准则。所以它是非常非常碎片化的。然后你还有不同的语言。南部省份说法语。北部和中部省份说荷兰语。在弗里斯兰，人们说弗里斯语，这是最接近英语的语言。有些人也说德语。而且这是16世纪中期，所以是宗教改革的全盛时期。因此存在各种宗教紧张局势和差异，
as well. And Protestantism has spread like wildfire across all the 17 provinces. And this unlike in England, where it's been very much imposed by the Tudor monarchy, Henry the 8th, and Edward the 6th and Elizabeth I. In the low countries, this is much more of a kind of top up. It doesn't have official sponsorship from the top. And the consequence of this is that there isn't anyone to impose any sense of control. So all these kind of various sects and factions is very, very wild west. Because although obviously they're happy to protest against Catholicism, there isn't any sense of coherence.
也是如此。新教像野火一样蔓延到所有17个省份。这与英国不同，英国的新教很大程度上是由都铎王朝、亨利八世、爱德华六世和伊丽莎白一世强加的。在低地国家，这更多是一种自下而上的运动。它没有来自顶层的官方支持。结果就是没有人能实施任何控制。所以所有这些各种各样的教派和派系就像狂野的西部。因为虽然他们显然乐于抗议天主教，但没有任何连贯性。
They all have kind of different views on what really matters. Now that said, by the middle of the 16th century, there is one particular brand of Protestantism, which is starting to emerge as the dominant. And this is what will become known as Calvinism, named after Jean Calvin, this great reformer. And he has kind of instituted this very disciplined, self-governing kind of church structure. And so Calvinism far more than the other sects can provide Protestants with, yeah, kind of, sense of coherence, really, a sense of structure that exists outside the structures of the organised state. So to quote Jonathan Israel, he's written the definitive book on the history of the Dutch Republic. Those this made by the profusion of reformations around them found the
他们对什么才是重要的有不同的看法。话虽如此，到16世纪中期，有一种特定的新教开始成为主导。这就是后来被称为加尔文主义的教派，以伟大的改革者让·加尔文命名。他建立了一种纪律严明、自治的教会结构。因此，加尔文主义比其他教派更能为新教徒提供一种连贯性，一种存在于有组织国家结构之外的结构感。所以引用乔纳森·以色列的话，他写了关于荷兰共和国历史的权威著作：那些被周围众多的宗教改革所困扰的人，在加尔文身上找到了他们渴望的解药。因此，起义的性质在很大程度上将是加尔文主义的。你提到了碎片化、700种不同的法律准则、不同的语言等等。但低地国家之间肯定有共同点，不是吗？我的意思是，坦率地说，当你今天去参观时，在建筑或文化等方面都能看到它们。即使在16世纪也是如此。有很多东西将这些后来成为比利时、荷兰和卢森堡的人民团结在一起。而且低地国家至今仍有许多连续性。所以他们以啤酒闻名，无论是荷兰的阿姆斯特尔啤酒，还是比利时那些
antidote for which they thirsted in Calvin. And so the character of the revolt as it emerges will be largely Calvinist. You made the point about the fragmentation, the 700 different legal codes, different languages and so on. But there are definitely commonalities across the low countries, aren't there? I mean, more frankly, you see them today when you visit in architecturally or culturally or whatever. And that's the case even back in the 16th century. There's more, well, not more, but there are a lot of things that unite the people of these, what become Belgium, Holland and Luxembourg. And there are often kind of continuities with the low countries to this day. So they're famous for their beer, whether it's Amstall in the Netherlands or all those
特拉普派啤酒。我喜欢比利时啤酒。当时的人均日消费量即使在英国游客看来也是巨大的。所以他们很震惊，成年人每天喝三品脱啤酒。而且我认为这不仅仅是淡啤酒。我的意思是，这是那种真正的、真正的酒精啤酒。同样，就像今天一样，女性以她们的清洁而闻名。这是一个贯穿荷兰共和国至今的主题。
trappist beers in Belgium. Love a Belgian beer. And the average daily consumption back then was seen as being enormous even by English visitors. So they were stunned that adults were drinking three pints of beer a day. And I don't think this was just the weak beer. I mean, this was kind of proper, proper alcoholic beer. And again, a bit like today, the women were famous for their kind of cleanliness. This is a theme that runs throughout the Dutch Republic and into the present day.
荷兰人以痴迷于清洁而闻名。但他们也因穿迷你裙而臭名昭著。在16世纪，这意味着裙子下摆到脚踝。所以非常令人震惊。是的，难以置信。所以他们既干净，又带有一点放荡的暗示。放荡。男人们被认为高得惊人。
The Dutch are famously obsessed with cleanliness. but also they were notorious for wearing mini skirts. And in the 16th century, this meant skirts that came down to the ankles. So very shocking. Yeah, unbelievable. So simultaneously, cleanly, but of a little hint of licentious. Licentiousness. The men are seen as being astoundingly tall.
所以许多人身高超过六英尺。同样，你知道，游客们觉得这很惊人。而且正如我们所说，这是一个高度城市化的社会。游客们无法相信它的人口密度有多高。所以大约每平方英里有90人。实际上，低地国家的人口并不比英国少多少，而英国的表面积要大得多。
So many are over six foot. And again, you know, visitors find this astonishing. And it's just, you know, we said this is a very urbanized society. visitors cannot believe how densely populated it is. So it's kind of 90 people per square mile. And effectively, the population of the low countries isn't that much smaller than England, which has a much, much kind of larger surface area.
对于那些真正挤在一起的人来说，这就是他们如此干净的原因。他们如此注重清洁，因为他们如此密集地生活在城市里。是的。最重要的是，在1548年，一种宪法统一性被强加给这17个省份，
To the people who are really packed in, that's why they're so clean. They're so cleanliness, because they're living so densely in cities. Yeah. And on top of that, in 1548, a kind of constitutional unity had been imposed on these 17 provinces,
凌驾于所有不同的特许状和法律体系之上，使它们成为一个统一的尼德兰。这是伟大的哈布斯堡皇帝查理五世的作品，他同时也是西班牙国王查理一世。作为西班牙国王查理一世，由于科尔特斯和皮萨罗的努力，他成为了墨西哥和秘鲁的国王。所以他是一个非常令人生畏的人物。这17个省份此前曾是神圣罗马帝国的一部分，查理作为皇帝统治着该帝国。但通过1548年的这项法案，它们被授予了某种法律和宪法上的独立性，脱离了帝国。所以它们现在实际上作为一个独立的统一体存在。引用荷兰起义的另一位伟大历史学家杰弗里·帕克的话，他认为在正常情况下，这可能构成了永久政治单位的基础。
kind of overriding all the different charters and legal systems and things, and making them kind of a united Netherlands. And this had been the work of the great Hapsburg Emperor Charles V, who also ruled as Charles I of Spain. And as Charles I of Spain, he had become king of Mexico and of Peru, thanks to the efforts of Cortez and Pizarro. So he is, you know, he probably rules a larger emperor,
帕克建议将其与中世纪成为瑞士的联盟，以及正处于这一时期从伊比利亚半岛内各种王国合并中崛起的西班牙进行比较。当然，这是一个非常有趣的观点。问题是：瑞士证明了你可以用不同的语言做到这一点，这并非不可能，西班牙的各种制度也是如此。为什么这在低地国家没有发生？
empire, certainly a more global empire than anyone has done in history. I mean, he's a very formidable figure. And the 17 provinces had previously been part of the Holy Roman Empire, which Charles rules as emperor. But they've been granted by this kind of act of 1548, a kind of legal and constitutional independence from the empire. So they now kind of effectively, they stand alone as a separate unity. and to quote another great historian of the Dutch revolt, Geoffrey Parker, he suggests that in normal circumstances, this might have formed the basis for a permanent political unit.
我的意思是，这把我们带到了国歌背后的故事，不是吗？确实。虽然故事非常复杂，荷兰起义爆发的原因有很多，但我认为你可以用更简单的术语将其描述为《威廉颂》第一段中提到的两个男人之间的对决。
And Parker suggests as parallels the unions that became Switzerland in the Middle Ages, and Spain, which is emerging at exactly this period from, you know, the union of all the various kingdoms within Iberia. Of course, that's such an interesting point. Here's the question. So, well, Switzerland proves that you could do it with different languages, that it's not impossible, and different institutions in Spain as well, of course. Why doesn't it happen in the low countries?
第一个当然是拿骚的威廉，也就是《威廉颂》中据说是叙述行动的亲王。那么他是谁？他出生于1533年，是德国拿骚伯爵的长子。这就是为什么他被称为拿骚的威廉。威廉的父亲来自莱茵兰。荷兰王室网站上翻译为“荷兰”的词也可以指“德国”。所以是德意志。因此，在某种意义上，拿骚的威廉实际上比荷兰人更像德国人。他也是路德宗信徒。所以年轻的威廉是作为新教徒抚养长大的。虽然他出身贵族，但他的家庭穷得叮当响，他们真的几乎没有什么前景，
I mean, this takes us to the story that lies behind the anthem, doesn't it? It does. And I think although the story is surprisingly very complicated and the reasons why the Dutte Revolt breaks out, there are many of them, I think you can frame it in much simpler terms as having been a showdown between the two men who were mentioned in that first verse,
无论是经济上还是在欧洲舞台上崭露头角。但随后在1544年发生了一件绝对的重磅炸弹，就像查尔斯·狄更斯小说里的情节一样，威廉突然发现他有巨大的期望，因为他的一位远房表亲，一个恰好是奥兰治亲王的人（奥兰治是法国最南端的一个城市），在法国的一次围城战中无嗣而终，他将所有的头衔和地产都留给了年轻的威廉。他没有任何更近的亲属。所以一瞬间，这个小男孩变得极其富有，成为了欧洲各地地产和各种财产的继承人。
of the Wilhelmus. And the first of these, of course, is William of Nassau, the prince who is supposedly narrating the action in the Wilhelmus. So who is he? So he was born in 1533, and he was the elder son of the Count of Nassau in Germany. So that's is why he's described as William of Nassau. And William's father is from the Rhineland. And the word that is translated as Dutch in that account on the Dutch royal family website can also mean German. So it's Deutsche. Deutschen. So there's a sense in which William of Nassau is actually more German than he is Dutch. He's also a Lutheran. So he's been raised as a Protestant, the young William. And he is, although he's of noble blood, his family is unbelievably skinned. They really have very few prospects,
关键的财产是奥兰治，这是一个亲王国，它是主权的，被法国包围，但它只对威廉效忠。所以他现在是奥兰治亲王。此外，还有低地国家的大片土地，包括布拉班特的大约四分之一，其中包含安特卫普，所以这是一个极其富有的地区。这成为了威廉遗产的实际核心。此外，我还要读出威廉继承的其他财产清单：他对法国消失的阿尔勒王国拥有主权要求。
either financial or kind of, very few prospects of making cutting a dash on the state. of Europe. But then in 1544 there's this absolute bombshell and it's like something out of a kind of Charles Dickens novel or something, suddenly William discovers that he has the most tremendous expectations because a very distant cousin of his, a guy who happens to be the Prince of Orange, which is a city in the distant southernmost reaches of France, dies childless in a siege in France, and he leaves all his titles and estates to the young William. He doesn't have any closer relation. So at a stroke, this young boy becomes fabulously rich and heir to estates and lands and all kinds of properties all over Europe.
他在普利亚有一个公国，他在意大利有三个亲王国，换句话说，他是四重亲王，16个伯爵领地，两个侯爵领地，两个子爵领地，50个男爵领地和大约300个较小的地产。他真的拥有……但代价是他必须放弃他不朽的灵魂。是这样吗？他必须放弃他的路德宗信仰。他挣扎了大约三秒钟，然后说，好吧，随便吧。
And the key property is Orange, which is a princedom, it's sovereign, it's enclosed within France. but, you know, it owes loyalty only to William. So he is now William of Orange. Also, huge chunks of the low countries, including about a quarter of Brabant, which includes Antwerp, so, you know, incredibly wealthy area to have. And this becomes the effective heart of William's inheritance. And additionally, and I'll just read out the list of other properties that William is inherited, he has a claim to the vanished kingdom of Arles, again in France.
我会很高兴地成为一名天主教徒。他认真对待了这一点。我认为他所有的家人都支持他，说，是的，这是正确的决定。对。我的意思是，这就像获得了霍格沃茨的巨额奖学金一样。突然之间，你被移植到了一个完全不同的社会秩序中，那里有你从未想象过的机会向你敞开。因为威廉去了布鲁塞尔查理五世的宫廷。所以当查理五世在低地国家时，他就在那里。
He has a dukedom in Apulia. he has three Italian principalities, so he's a prince four times over, in other words, 16 countships, two margravates, two Viscountancies, 50 baronies and some 300 smaller estates. He really has. But the price for this is that he has to give up his immortal soul. Is that right? He has to give up his Lutheranism. He wrestles with it for about three seconds, and then he says, fine, whatever.
查理五世认为这个小男孩非常了不起，并培养他成为哈布斯堡宫廷的大人物之一。到1555年威廉22岁时，他已经成为查理随从中最高贵的人物。所以他迷人、奢侈，被赋予了战争经验，有政治经验。我的意思是，他是完美的化身。1555年10月，查理五世著名地开始退位。他在布鲁塞尔将低地国家的领主权让位给他的儿子菲利普，也就是后来成为西班牙国王菲利普二世的人，那个派遣西班牙无敌舰队对抗英国的人。但此时，年迈的查理五世，他当时已经非常跛了。
I'll very happily become a Catholic. He took that seriously. And I think all his family kind of swing behind him and say, yeah, this is the right decision. Right. I mean, it's kind of like getting a massive scholarship to Hogwarts or something. Suddenly, you are being transplanted to a completely different order of society in which opportunities are open to up to you that you had never even imagined. Because William goes off to the court of Charles V in Brussels. So the place where Charles V is based when he's in the low countries.
他拄着拐杖。但用另一只手臂，他倚靠在奥兰治亲王身上走向祭坛，进行正式退位。这种象征意义大概是，他是他们的人。他是他们现场的人，他们的当地合作者，因为他们基本上一直在培养他作为哈布斯堡王朝在低地国家的代表，对吧？他将作为他们在低地国家的副手。
And Charles V thinks this young boy is tremendous and grooms him to become one of the big players at the Habsburg Court. And by 1555, when William is 22, he has become the most glamorous figure in Charles's train. So he's charming, he's extravagant, he's being given experience in war, he's experienced in politics. I mean, he's the complete article. And that October of 1555, Charles V, famously starts abdicating his very powers. And he's in Brussels to abdicate his lordship of the low countries in favour of his son, Philip, who is going to go on to become Philip the second of Spain, the man who sends the Spanish Armada against England. But at this point, the elderly Charles V, he's very lame by this point.
这之所以重要，是因为查理五世的儿子菲利普在仪式上成为了尼德兰的新领主。但不久之后，他将前往西班牙成为西班牙国王菲利普二世。西班牙是一个比低地国家大得多、强大得多的领土集合体。当然，它还附带了新世界的所有那些辉煌的财产。所以毫无疑问，菲利普基本上会以那里为基地。当然，他会建造著名的埃斯科里亚尔宫，在山上，基本上被藏在那里。所以他需要人
He's got a stick. But with his other arm, he is leaning on the Prince of Orange as he goes up to the altar. to offer his formal abdication. And the symbolism of this, presumably, is that he is their man. He is their man on the spot, their local collaborator, because they've basically been training him as the Habsburg representative, I guess, in the low countries, haven't they? He's going to serve kind of as their deputy in the low countries.
在低地国家为他管理。他确实依赖威廉作为他在那里的副官。关键的法律形式化出现在1559年，当时菲利普任命威廉为荷兰、泽兰和乌得勒支的省督或总督。换句话说，是低地国家北部的核心省份。我的意思是，在这一点上，你会说，一切都准备好了。你知道，他们有了他们的人。在这个阶段，没有任何迹象表明威廉会想越界。我的意思是，他为什么要这样做？对他来说情况很好。嗯，而且他对哈布斯堡王朝非常忠诚。查理五世对他非常好。所以，当然，这永远不会出现在他的脑海里。这会违背他所有的准则和忠诚。
And the reason why that is important is that Charles V's son, Philip, is becoming the new Lord of the Netherlands in the ceremony. But shortly afterwards, he is going to go to Spain and become Philip the second of Spain. And Spain is a much larger, much more powerful conglomeration of territories than the low countries. And of course, it also comes with all those brilliant possessions in the new world. So there's no question that Philip is essentially going to base himself there. And of course, he's going to build this famous palace, the Escorial, up in the mountains, and essentially kind of end up squirreled away there. So he needs people
但我想有两个令人烦恼的问题，随着时间的推移会变得越来越糟。第一个是菲利普和威廉之间存在性格冲突。因为菲利普非常内向。他口吃，非常理智，非常勤奋，非常虔诚，非常虔诚的天主教徒。而威廉是一个巨大的外向者。他是个小伙子。每个人都喜欢他。他喜欢跳舞。
in the low countries to administer it for him. And he does rely on William to serve him as his lieutenant there. And the key legal formalization of this comes in 1559 when Philip appoints William as the governor or stadtholder of Holland, Zeeland and Utrecht. So in other words, the core provinces in the north of the low countries. I mean, at this point, you would say, well, all is set fair. You know, they've got their placeman. There's absolutely no hint at this stage that William would ever want to step out of line. I mean, why would he? Things are good for him. Well, and he's very loyal to the Habsburgs. Charles V has been, you know, very good to him. So, of course, it would never cross his mind. It would go against all his codes, all his loyalties.
他喜欢嬉戏。所有这些。所以他们非常非常不同。我认为政治紧张局势也在加剧，因为随着岁月的流逝，菲利普作为低地国家的领主，却从不出现在那里。很明显，他本质上是一位西班牙国王。所以低地国家的人们开始感到他们从属于他，就像殖民地人民从属于遥远的主人或霸主一样。对西班牙在低地国家存在的怨恨开始增长。
But there are, I think, kind of two niggling problems, which will over the course of the years become worse and worse. And the first of these is that there is a personality clash between Philip and William. Because Philip is very, I think, is an introvert. He's tongue-tied. He's very intellectual. he's very studious, he's very devout, very devout Catholic. And William is a massive extrovert. He's a lad. Everyone loves him. He loves a dance.
菲利普任命了西班牙大臣进入国务委员会，该委员会本应管理这些省份。他在关键城市部署了西班牙驻军。他授权西班牙宗教裁判所去搜捕异端。虽然威廉当然为了成为奥兰治亲王而成为了天主教徒，但他不是一个教条主义的天主教徒。他没有皈依者的狂热。
He loves a frolic. All of that. So they're very, very different. I think there are also growing political tensions because as the years go by and Philip, who is, you know, he is the lord of the low countries, but he's never there. And it becomes clear that fundamentally he is a, Spanish king. And so people in the low countries start to feel that they are subordinate to him in the manner of a colonial people subject to a distant master or overlord. And resentment of the
不，他没有。他担心宗教裁判所的行动可能对低地国家的公民和谐意味着什么。他的担忧在1559年夏天发生的一件事中得到了澄清。威廉作为临时人质被派往法国宫廷。当时正在进行谈判。所以威廉不得不作为法国国王亨利二世的客人待在那里几个月。
Spanish presence in the low country starts to grow and grow. So Philip has appointed Spanish ministers to the Council of State, which is supposed to administer these provinces. He's installed Spanish garrisons in the key cities. And he has licensed the Spanish Inquisition. to start sniffing out heresy. And although William, of course, has become a Catholic as a requirement for becoming the Prince of Orange, he's not a doctrinaire Catholic. He doesn't have the zeal of a convert.
他受到了很好的照顾。正如我们所说，他是一个巨大的外向者。人们真的很喜欢他。他们认为他很有趣。所以他成了亨利二世的好朋友。亨利带他去沙特尔的树林里打猎。在打猎时，亨利说漏了嘴。
No, he doesn't. And he is worried about what the actions of the Inquisition might mean for kind of civic harmony in the low countries. And his concerns are clarified for him by one episode in particular, which happens in the summer of 1559. And William has been sent as a temporary hostage to the court of France. There's kind of treating negotiations going on. And so for a few months, William has to stay there as the guest of Henry II, the king of France.
向威廉透露了一个令人震惊的秘密，显然是假设威廉已经知道了。亨利向威廉透露，他，法国国王，和西班牙国王菲利普二世，对新教在基督教世界的增长感到如此恐惧，以至于他们达成了一项针对新教徒（亨利和菲利普眼中的异端）的全面灭绝政策。他们的希望是，最终这项灭绝政策将涵盖整个基督教世界，正如亨利所说。但计划是从低地国家开始。威廉听到这些时，感到非常震惊。但他没有透露这对他来说是完全的新闻。
And he's looked after very well. He is, as we've said, a massive extrovert. People really like him. They think he's great fun. And so he becomes great mates with Henry II. And Henry takes him out hunting in the woods of Chanty. And while they're at hunting, Henry lets sleep. a shocking secret to William on the assumption evidently that William already knows about it.
你知道，他保持着扑克脸。部分原因我认为是出于自我保护。他不想让菲利普知道他反对这项政策。而且我认为这也是因为威廉可能并不完全相信亨利告诉他的话，他认为最好的政策可能是静观其变。也许这实际上不会是一项灭绝政策。也许法国国王夸大了。你知道，如果实际上不会有问题，他不想大惊小怪。所以他对此保持沉默。法国国王在那里有点夸大其词，不是吗？我的意思是，他，你知道，
And Henry reveals to William that he, the King of France, and Philip II, the King of Spain, have become so terrified by the growth of Protestantism in Christendom that they have agreed a full-scale policy of extermination against the Protestants, the heretics, as Henry and Philip see them. And their hope is that ultimately this policy of extermination will embrace the entire Christian world, as Henry puts it. But the plan is to begin with the low countries. And William, when he's told this, is absolutely appalled. But he doesn't let slip the fact that it's come as complete news to him.
在接下来的几年里，当你，你知道，威廉保持沉默时，他确实保持沉默。低地国家没有针对新教徒的种族灭绝运动。有运动，但并不像那次谈话所暗示的那样具有灭绝性。当发生了一系列大规模处决，包括处决贵族领袖时，那一刻到来了。我认为这被视为所有对菲利普政策感到焦虑的人的一个关键点，他们认为这是压迫性的，这确实是点燃荷兰起义火药桶的火花。
You know, he keeps a poker face. And partly I think this is out of self-preservation. He doesn't want, you know, news to reach Philip that he disapproves. of this policy. And I think it's also because maybe William doesn't entirely trust what he's being told by Henry and he thinks it the best policy might be just to wait and see. Maybe it won't actually be an exterminatory policy. Maybe the French King's exaggerating. You know, he doesn't want to make a massive fuss if there isn't actually going to be a problem. And so he keeps stum about it. The French King is exaggerating a bit there, isn't he? I mean, he's, you know,
但问题是，在整个这段时期，威廉仍然是他一直以来的样子，非常迷人、善于交际、口才流利等等。所以他绝不是一个沉默寡言的人，你知道，正如我们所说，是一个外向者，而不是内向者。但时间到了，它将被菲利普授权的这一系列针对新教徒和疑似叛军的大规模处决所触发。那时他将不得不决定他要做什么。他是要保持对菲利普和哈布斯堡王朝的忠诚？还是他要站在他已经开始认同的人一边？
for the next few years, when, when you said, you know, William keeps quiet, he does keep quiet. there is no genocidal campaign against Protestants in the low countries. There are campaigns, but they're not as exterminatory as that conversation might suggest. The moment comes where there is a kind of mass cycle of executions, including the execution of leading members of the nobility. And I think that this is seen as a kind of crunch point for all kinds of people who've been anxious about Phillips policy, sees it as repressive, and really is the kind of the spark that lights the tinderbox of the Dutch revolt.
在接下来的几年里，正如你所说，威廉保持沉默，他确实保持了沉默。在低地国家并没有针对新教徒的种族灭绝运动。虽然确实存在一些运动，但并不像那次谈话所暗示的那样具有灭绝性。后来出现了一个大规模处决周期，包括处决贵族中的领袖人物。我认为这被所有对菲利普的政策感到焦虑的人视为一个关键转折点，他们认为这是一种压迫，这确实是点燃荷兰起义火药桶的导火索。
But the thing is that during this whole period, William remains what he's always been, kind of very charming, sociable, fluent, and so on. So very much not a taciturned man, you know, an extrovert, not an introvert, as we've said. But the time is coming and it will be triggered by this kind of great cycle of executions of Protestants and suspected rebels that Philip licenses. when he will have to decide what he's going to do. Is he going to stay loyal to Philip and to the Habsburgs? Or is he going to take the side of people whom he has come to identify with
但问题在于，在整个这段时期，威廉依然保持着他一贯的样子，非常有魅力、善于交际、口才流利等等。所以他绝不是一个沉默寡言的人，正如我们所说，他是一个外向者，而不是内向者。但时机终将到来，并将由菲利普许可的这一系列针对新教徒和疑似叛乱分子的大规模处决所触发。届时他将不得不决定自己该怎么做。他是要继续效忠菲利普和哈布斯堡王朝，还是站在他已经开始认同的那些人一边？
and whom he is starting to see as directly oppressed? And when he makes his decision, which is to side with the rebels, he makes clear that his anxieties have been kind of germinating all this time. and he has been keeping quiet about it. He's been hiding them. He's been, you know, that is definitely not not something that he's been talking about. And so William of Orange will come to be remembered by the Dutch, not for his kind of incredible fluency, not for his master of the social arts, but for the opposite. And he will come to be known by the Dutch as Willem des Weyzeweig.
以及他开始将谁视为直接受压迫的人？当他做出决定，即站在叛军一边时，他清楚地表明，他的焦虑一直都在萌芽。他一直对此保持沉默。他一直在隐藏这些焦虑。你知道，这绝对不是他一直在谈论的事情。因此，奥兰治亲王威廉被荷兰人铭记，不是因为他那令人难以置信的口才，也不是因为他精通社交艺术，而是恰恰相反。他将被荷兰人称为“沉默者威廉”。
William the Silent and this is how he is known by history and it's kind of fantastic that it is in the voice of William the Silent that the Dutch team will be singing the national anthem when they meet Sweden this coming weekend. All right so we will take a break and then after the break we will find out what happens to William the Silent and indeed the Dutch Revolt
沉默者威廉，这就是他在历史上的称呼。令人称奇的是，本周末荷兰队在对阵瑞典队时，将以“沉默者威廉”的声音唱响国歌。好了，我们先休息一下，休息之后，我们将了解沉默者威廉以及荷兰起义的后续。
and how the anthem is born. This episode is brought to you by the Times and the Sunday Times. Tom has another summer of top international football returns. It's truly incredible, isn't it, to think about how much the world has changed between the various tournaments. Looking back to when England hosted back in 1966,
以及国歌是如何诞生的。本期节目由《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》为您呈现。汤姆又迎来了一个顶级国际足球之夏。回想一下，在不同的锦标赛之间，世界发生了多大的变化，这真是令人难以置信，不是吗？回望1966年英格兰主办的那届比赛，
everyone in the crowd supporting England were waving Union jacks. So what fascinating trends does that illustrate? And I suppose the last time the United States hosted the tournament was in 1994. And the mood in America in the early 1990s, you know, the Cold War was over, Clinton was in the White House. I was there for that. I was in Boston. Really? I mean, that's an aspect of the story that's very rarely reported on your presence. So you know what this reminds me of, Tom? It reminds me that the future
人群中支持英格兰的每个人都在挥舞着联合杰克旗。那么，这说明了什么迷人的趋势呢？我想美国上一次主办锦标赛是在1994年。90年代初美国的氛围，你知道，冷战结束了，克林顿入主白宫。我当时就在那里。我在波士顿。真的吗？我的意思是，这是关于你的经历中极少被报道的一个故事侧面。所以你知道这让我想起了什么吗，汤姆？它让我想起未来
is always uncertain. You never know what's coming. But the facts need not be uncertain. And when the world feels like it's moving too fast, the times and the Sunday times empower you to make smarter, more confident decisions. Click or tap the banner now to learn more or visit the times.com. Hi everybody. We have an absolutely thrilling announcement for you. That's right, Dominic. We are putting on another night for you at the South Bank on Friday the 4th of September. We will be bringing you the ultimate Victorian adventure. Yes, it really is the maddest expedition in history. You've got to create a
总是充满不确定性。你永远不知道接下来会发生什么。但事实不必是不确定的。当世界感觉发展太快时，《泰晤士报》和《星期日泰晤士报》能让你做出更明智、更自信的决定。点击或轻触横幅了解更多信息，或访问thetimes.com。大家好。我们有一个非常激动人心的消息要宣布。没错，多米尼克。我们将于9月4日星期五在南岸为你们举办另一场晚会。我们将为您带来终极的维多利亚时代冒险。是的，这确实是历史上最疯狂的探险。你必须创造一个
crazy African emperor, kidnapping British citizens. You've got Queen Victoria sending a rescue mission halfway around the world to get them back. It's General Gordon, but turned up to 11. And the biggest twist of all is the fact that this is a story that has never before been heard on The Rest is History. So it is a world exclusive. Unbelievable drama. So we're hoping to see as many people as possible. You can get the tickets again by going to the rest is history.com. Tickets go on sale at 10 o'clock this morning, Tuesday the 16th of June. And here's the really thrilling news. Included in your ticket is a copy of our super-soreaway new book, a history of the world in 51 heroes and villains. So you'll get the book, you'll get to see us, it will genuinely be the best thing you've ever done in your entire life.
疯狂的非洲皇帝，绑架英国公民。维多利亚女王派出一支救援队穿越半个地球去营救他们。这就是戈登将军，但程度被调到了11级。最令人意想不到的转折是，这是一个在《历史的其余部分》中从未被讲述过的故事。所以这是一个世界独家新闻。令人难以置信的戏剧性。我们希望尽可能多的人能来参加。你可以再次通过访问therestishistory.com获取门票。门票将于6月16日星期二今天上午10点开售。这里有一个非常激动人心的消息。你的门票包含我们超级畅销的新书《51位英雄与恶棍的世界史》的副本。所以你不仅能得到书，还能见到我们，这绝对会是你一生中做过的最棒的事情。
And don't forget, tickets are on sale now. A shield and my reliance. Oh God, though ever, word, I'll trust until thy guidance, O leave me not ungirt, that I may stay a pious servant of thine for I, and drive the plagues that try us and tyranny
别忘了，门票现已开售。你是我的盾牌和依靠。哦，上帝，无论何时，我都将信赖你的指引，哦，请不要让我卸下武装，让我成为你虔诚的仆人，因为我，要驱散那些考验我们的瘟疫和暴政。
away. So that is the sixth verse, the sixth of, what was it, 324 verses? Yeah, 15. 15 in total. The sixth verse of the Wilhelmus, the Dutch National Anthem, and that is from the Royal House
走开。这就是第六节，324节中的第六节？是的，总共15节。15节。这是荷兰国歌《威廉颂》的第六节，这是来自荷兰王室
of the Netherlands's own website, the English translation. So 15 verses. The first letters of these 15 verses form an acrostic, don't they? And they spell the name, Willem van Nassoff, William of Nassau, William of Orange, William the Silent. And interestingly, when they're singing the anthem before matches, the Dutch team, they sing the first verse and the sixth verse. So it's mad that they actually sing that verse where they pledge allegiance to the Spain. What happens when they, in 2010, at the World Cup final, when they played Spain and disgraced themselves? Yeah, well, the Spanish don't have any words at all.
自己的网站，英文翻译。所以是15节。这15节的首字母组成了一个藏头诗，不是吗？它们拼出了“Willem van Nassoff”的名字，即拿骚的威廉，奥兰治亲王威廉，沉默者威廉。有趣的是，荷兰队在比赛前唱国歌时，他们唱的是第一节和第六节。所以他们竟然唱那节宣誓效忠西班牙的歌词，真是太疯狂了。2010年世界杯决赛，当他们对阵西班牙并自取其辱时，发生了什么？是的，好吧，西班牙人根本没有歌词。
No, they don't. They must have find it nice for people to sing about them. I mean, you know, the 2010 World Cup final one, the Dutch played the Spanish, and the Dutch actually disgraced themselves in that final. But it must have been nice for the Spanish to have a little mention there in the anthem singing. Yeah, if they're king. Yeah, exactly. So why did they pair those two? So strange.
不，他们没有。他们一定觉得人们唱关于他们的歌很好。我的意思是，你知道，2010年世界杯决赛，荷兰队对阵西班牙队，荷兰队在那场决赛中确实自取其辱。但对于西班牙人来说，在国歌中被提及一定很不错。是的，如果他们是国王的话。是的，完全正确。那他们为什么要配对这两者呢？太奇怪了。
sixth verse is full of biblical resonance, Dominic. So it's a kind of reminder that William had faced utter ruin, but had lived to tell the tale, because God is his shield and his reliance. And I think specifically, and this is made clear a couple of verses on from the sixth verse, he's been compared to King David, who's the biblical hero, who'd become the favorite of Saul, who was Israel's first king, by killing Goliath with his sling, as a shepherd boy and David grows up and then Saul becomes very jealous of David, hunts David and tries to kill him, but David had survived and ultimately prevailed. So I think William is being cast as David and Philip II has been cast as kind of Saul, his former royal master who's turned against him.
第六节充满了圣经的共鸣，多米尼克。所以这是一种提醒，威廉曾面临彻底的毁灭，但却幸存下来讲述了这个故事，因为上帝是他的盾牌和依靠。我认为特别是在第六节之后的几节中，他被比作大卫王，那位圣经中的英雄，他通过用投石索杀死歌利亚，从牧羊少年成为了扫罗（以色列第一位国王）的宠儿，大卫长大后，扫罗变得非常嫉妒大卫，追捕并试图杀死他，但大卫幸存下来并最终获胜。所以我认为威廉被塑造成了大卫，而腓力二世被塑造成了扫罗，他曾经的皇家主人，现在却反目成仇。
Because of course, Philip had appointed William as Stadtholder of Holland and Zealand, had assumed that he could be relied on as a loyal servant of the Habsburg House. But as we were saying in the first half, all this time, William had been tracking Philip the Second's potentially exterminatory policies against the Protestants with a kind of growing sense of horror. And the time comes where he can no longer keep silent. And William the silent, you know, speaks out against the exactions of the Spanish. And specifically, he chooses to speak out in 1567, which is the year when Philip sends an army of 10,000 battle-hardened soldiers to the low countries.
因为当然，腓力曾任命威廉为荷兰和西兰的总督，本以为可以依靠他作为哈布斯堡家族的忠实仆人。但正如我们在上半场所说，一直以来，威廉都在以一种日益增长的恐惧感追踪腓力二世针对新教徒的潜在灭绝政策。当时间到来时，他再也无法保持沉默。沉默者威廉，你知道，公开反对西班牙人的勒索。特别是，他选择在1567年发声，那一年腓力向低地国家派遣了一支由1万名久经沙场的士兵组成的军队。
And its mandate is essentially to terrorize the heretics, the Protestants into submission and ultimately into oblivion. And as we said in the first half, thousands are executed. And among the people who were put to death are Williams close to its allies among the Dutch nobility. And had William remained in the low countries, he would have been put to death as well. But he has sensed the way the wind is blowing. He's starting to think, actually, all this stuff about exterminatory policy, it is actually true. And so he had retreated beyond Phillips' reach into his kind of German land. So he'd gone to the provinces beyond the frontier with the empire.
其使命本质上是恐吓异端分子和新教徒，迫使他们屈服，最终走向毁灭。正如我们在上半场所说，数千人被处决。在被处死的人中，有威廉在荷兰贵族中的亲密盟友。如果威廉留在低地国家，他也会被处死。但他已经察觉到了风向。他开始想，实际上，所有关于灭绝政策的事情，竟然是真的。于是他撤退到了腓力势力范围之外，进入了他的德国领地。所以他去了帝国边境之外的省份。
And while he's absent so effectively in exile, his properties in the low country are confiscated. So all those lands in Brabant, for instance. His eldest son is seized as a hostage and is taken to Spain and, you know, he won't come back to the low countries for decades and decades. And William himself is declared an outlaw. And the obvious choice at this point for William would have been to negotiate and to reach terms and to kind of essentially submit to Phillips' demands. But he is like David in the Bible. He refuses to give up. And so he mortgages all his properties, he takes out massive loans, and he funnels all the cash that he's raised into the cause of the resistance.
当他缺席并实际上流亡时，他在低地国家的财产被没收了。比如布拉班特的所有土地。他的长子被扣为人质并被带到西班牙，你知道，他几十年都不会回到低地国家。威廉本人也被宣布为逃犯。此时威廉显而易见的选择本应是谈判、达成协议，并基本上屈服于腓力的要求。但他就像圣经中的大卫。他拒绝放弃。于是他抵押了所有的财产，贷了巨款，并将筹集到的所有资金投入到抵抗事业中。
And he spends on two particular kind of modes of resistance. And the first of these are privateers. So essentially, pirates who are operating supposedly on behalf of whatever it is, this kind of rebellious proto-Dutch state. and there's a brilliant description of these pirates by C.V. Wedgwood. You know, you wrote that kind of wonderful trilogy on the English Civil War. So 1950s, I think she wrote this. It has that kind of 1950s feel. So she wrote, she described these pirates as weather-beaten ex-merchantman
他把钱花在两种特定的抵抗方式上。第一种是私掠船。本质上，就是代表某种叛乱的原始荷兰国家的所谓海盗。C.V.韦奇伍德对这些海盗有精彩的描述。你知道，她写了那部关于英国革命的精彩三部曲。我想是1950年代写的。它有一种50年代的感觉。所以她写道，她将这些海盗描述为饱经风霜的前商船船员，
with second-hand cannon nailed to splitting decks and patched sails, bellying in the wind, manned by ruffians and patriots, Dutchmen and French and English, the riff-raff of 20 ports, three nations, and fluttering at their mast heads. The orange trickler with the lion of Nassau. And they're the sea beggars, aren't they? And that's an insult from this. It's the classic example of someone insults you,
甲板开裂，钉着二手大炮，船帆打着补丁，在风中鼓起，由暴徒和爱国者、荷兰人、法国人和英国人组成，来自20个港口、三个国家的乌合之众，桅杆顶端飘扬着奥兰治的旗帜，上面有拿骚的狮子。他们就是“海上乞丐”，对吧？这是一个侮辱性的称呼。这是经典的例子，有人侮辱你，
and then you co-opt it, you appropriate the insult as a badge of pride. The sea beggars and what they are are basically ultra-protestant pirates. Yeah, Calvinist pirates. But just on the Protestantism, William the Silence is still a Catholic, is he? Yeah. And the revolt isn't just Protestants. There are still at this point, lots of Catholics. But we don't want to go too far into that.
然后你采纳了它，你把这个侮辱变成了荣誉的象征。海上乞丐，他们基本上是极端新教海盗。是的，加尔文派海盗。但关于新教，沉默者威廉当时还是天主教徒，对吧？是的。而且起义不仅仅是新教徒。当时还有很多天主教徒。但我们不想深入探讨这一点。
This is a national rising rather than a religious rising. It's definitely Protestant heavy, and it's taking place in the south as well as the north, because there are lots of, Antwerp, for instance, is definitely majority Calvinist at this point. And we are going to be looking at the intricacies of what some of this in a forthcoming series on the Tudor Cold War, about the kind of the way in which England and Spain fight, and the low countries will be one of the key battles. fields. But I mean, I think just to keep it kind of relatively clear at this point, I think it's easiest to think of the rebels as being Protestant. I mean, they're not exclusively, but largely. But as we say, the revolt spans the whole of the 17 provinces. And William, while these pirates
这是一场民族起义，而不是宗教起义。它确实有很强的新教色彩，而且在南方和北方都在发生，因为有很多，比如安特卫普，此时绝对是加尔文派占多数。我们将在即将推出的关于都铎冷战的系列节目中探讨其中一些复杂性，关于英国和西班牙战斗的方式，而低地国家将是关键战场之一。但我的意思是，为了保持相对清晰，我认为把叛军视为新教徒是最简单的。我的意思是，他们并非全部，但大部分是。但正如我们所说，起义跨越了全部17个省。而威廉，当这些海盗
are busy kind of roaming the seas in Yoho Hoing, he's been raising an army of mercenaries in Germany, and then he crosses the border, he invades, and he moves into Brabant, which is his own, that's where all his lands are, where he's got his feudal holdings, and his aim is to challenge the Spanish to battle. But the problem is the Spanish are far too experienced, far too smart, far too militarily savvy to fall into doing what William wants them to do. And so rather than meet his challenge, the Spanish hold to their positions and just wait for William to run out of money because they know that he only has a kind of finite supply. And sure enough, you know, after a few weeks, the money does run out and all his mercenaries say, well, we're not hanging around and they
忙着在海上游荡时，他一直在德国招募雇佣军，然后他越过边境，入侵并进入布拉班特，那是他自己的领地，是他所有土地所在的地方，他有封建领地，他的目标是挑战西班牙人进行战斗。但问题是西班牙人经验太丰富、太聪明、太精通军事，不会落入威廉想要的陷阱。因此，西班牙人没有接受他的挑战，而是坚守阵地，只是等待威廉耗尽资金，因为他们知道他的供应是有限的。果然，几周后，钱花光了，他所有的雇佣兵都说，好吧，我们不留在这里了，他们
melt away. And William has no choice but to retreat. And from that point on, things just go from bad to worst for William because he keeps mortgaging more and more of his properties. He keep launching or sponsoring invasions and they keep being defeated. And also on the domestic front, things have gone very badly wrong for William because he's got a new wife. And this is the daughter of the elector of Saxony. So I think it's an attempt by William to try and build relations with the Lutheran princes to the east. And she's called Anna. And she spends her whole time kind of cheating on him, getting drunk, accusing him of trying to poison her. And C. F. V. Wedgwood, who is a woman, she has this tremendous description of Anna of Saxony,
散去了。威廉别无选择，只能撤退。从那时起，威廉的情况每况愈下，因为他不断抵押更多的财产。他不断发起或赞助入侵，但不断被击败。而且在家庭方面，威廉的情况也非常糟糕，因为他有了新妻子。这是萨克森选帝侯的女儿。所以我认为这是威廉试图与东部的路德派诸侯建立关系。她叫安娜。她整天都在欺骗他，酗酒，指责他试图毒死她。C.F.V.韦奇伍德，她是一位女性，她对萨克森的安娜有极好的描述，
her own worst enemy. She advertised her follies as a woman and her failure as a wife. everywhere. God, that's harsh. It is harsh, isn't it? Yeah. It's really harsh. And crucially, he's running. I mean, the one thing he needs more than anything is money, and he's running out, isn't he? Yeah, I don't think that helps with Anna. I mean, you mentioned this is the Spanish strategy. So by what, 1572, he's down to his very last coppers. The coffers are bare, basically. Yeah, and the Spanish have managed to take back all the kind of rebellious towns and cities
她自己最大的敌人。她到处宣扬她作为女人的愚蠢和作为妻子的失败。天哪，这太刻薄了。确实很刻薄，不是吗？是的。真的很刻薄。关键是，他缺钱。我的意思是，他最需要的是钱，但他快没钱了，不是吗？是的，我不认为这对安娜有帮助。我的意思是，你提到这是西班牙的策略。所以到1572年，他已经到了山穷水尽的地步。国库基本上空了。是的，西班牙人已经成功夺回了所有叛乱的城镇和城市
across the low countries. So in footballing terms, they're kind of 10-0 down. I guess with maybe three minutes to go. I mean, they really look down and out. The only sign of life, really, in the revolt, are the sea beggars who are still kind of yarr, up and down the North Sea and into the English Channel, where they have their bases, because their Protestants, Elizabeth I first by this point,
在低地国家。所以用足球术语来说，他们以0比10落后。我想可能还剩三分钟。我的意思是，他们看起来真的完了。起义中唯一真正的生命迹象是海上乞丐，他们仍然在北海和英吉利海峡游荡，他们在那里有基地，因为他们是新教徒，伊丽莎白一世此时
is on the throne in England. She's Protestant, and she's given them bases. But the problem is, in 1572, Elizabeth is being leaned on by the Spanish, and Elizabeth is imbetrantly cautious and she thinks, well, the revolt's probably over. You know, I don't want to burn my bridges with the Spanish.
在英国王位上。她是新教徒，她给了他们基地。但问题是，在1572年，伊丽莎白受到西班牙人的压力，伊丽莎白极其谨慎，她想，好吧，起义可能结束了。你知道，我不想烧掉我和西班牙人的桥梁。
You know, they're not doing any good. I'll chuck them out. And so she closes their English bases to the sea beggars. And they're now roaming the sea and they haven't really got anywhere to go. But then Dominic, from the depths of despair, a sudden, incredible comeback. It's like when Holland played Argentina in the last World Cup, although they actually then went out on penalties,
你知道，他们没做什么好事。我会把他们赶出去。于是她关闭了海上乞丐的英国基地。他们现在在海上游荡，真的无处可去。但随后，多米尼克，从绝望的深渊中，突然出现了令人难以置信的复出。就像荷兰在上一届世界杯对阵阿根廷时一样，尽管他们实际上在点球大战中出局了，
but that's by the bye. It's an incredible comeback. But this is even more incredible. This is a comeback that doesn't end in penalty tragedy. Because on the 1st of April, 1572, the sea beggars arrive off a port called Brill, which is a strategically crucial port on an island, kind of in the great estuary, which leads out from Antwerp, and it effectively controls the waterways of Holland and Zealand. So very strategically crucial. and they sail up towards this port, and to their astonishment, they find that it's empty because the entire garrison has gone off fishing.
但那是题外话。这是一个令人难以置信的复出。但这更令人难以置信。这是一个没有以点球悲剧告终的复出。因为在1572年4月1日，海上乞丐抵达了一个叫布里尔的港口，这是一个战略上至关重要的港口，位于一个岛屿上，在通往安特卫普的大河口，它有效地控制了荷兰和西兰的水道。所以战略上非常关键。他们向这个港口航行，令他们惊讶的是，他们发现它是空的，因为整个驻军都去钓鱼了。
They assume that, you know, the war is effectively over. And so for the sea beggars, this is a complete open goal. And they sail into the port, and they occupy it. And they sack all the Catholic churches. They give assurances to the inhabitants that all will be well treated except priests, monks, and papists. So that's a reassurance. And they set about turning it into a rebel stronghold. And with this base, because it is so strategic,
他们认为，你知道，战争实际上已经结束了。所以对于海上乞丐来说，这是一个完全的空门。他们驶入港口并占领了它。他们洗劫了所有的天主教堂。他们向居民保证，除了牧师、僧侣和教皇信徒外，所有人都会受到善待。所以这是一种安慰。他们开始把它变成一个叛军据点。有了这个基地，因为它如此具有战略意义，
suddenly they're able to go on the offensive and they start banging in goals left, right and center. Great, footballing imagery now. Thank you. Thank you, Dominic. And the rest of the team, to pursue the metaphor, are roused from their torpor. Right. And suddenly you get Calvinists in towns across Holland and Zealand are rising up. they're expelling the Spanish garrisons and they are declaring for William of Orange.
突然间他们能够发起进攻，他们开始左右开弓进球。现在是伟大的足球意象。谢谢。谢谢，多米尼克。团队的其他成员，用这个比喻来说，从昏睡中被唤醒了。对。突然间，荷兰和西兰各城镇的加尔文派信徒纷纷起义。他们驱逐了西班牙驻军，并宣布支持奥兰治亲王威廉。
And by July, representatives from these two provinces, so Holland and Zealand, are ready to acknowledge William basically as the guy in charge. And specifically, they confirm him in the office that Philip had originally bestowed on him. So that's the office of Stadtholder, of governor. And obviously, it is slightly awkward that William's office derives from the King of Spain. But the rebels in Holland and Zealand have a kind of way around this. And there wheezes to say that, yes, William is the loyal servant of the King of Spain. And he's proving his loyalty to the King of Spain by attacking the Spanish.
到七月，这两个省（荷兰和西兰）的代表准备承认威廉基本上是负责人。具体来说，他们确认了他最初由腓力授予的职位。也就是总督的职位。显然，威廉的职位源于西班牙国王，这有点尴尬。但荷兰和西兰的叛军有一种解决办法。他们的诡计是说，是的，威廉是西班牙国王的忠实仆人。他通过攻击西班牙人来证明他对西班牙国王的忠诚。
And that may sound a slight stretch to people. So how can this make sense? It's because the pretenses that Philip doesn't know what his generals and his soul and his administrators are doing in his name and would be appalled if he did. So it's the classic, you know, the king doesn't know what his servants are doing. I was about to say this is a classic medieval or early modern device, rhetorical device. It's the king is great. We love the king.
这对人们来说可能听起来有点牵强。那么这怎么能说得通呢？这是因为假装腓力不知道他的将军、他的灵魂和他的行政人员以他的名义在做什么，如果他知道的话会感到震惊。所以这是经典的，你知道，国王不知道他的仆人在做什么。我正要说这是经典的中古或近代手段，修辞手段。国王是伟大的。我们爱国王。
It's just these corrupt and evil advisors. Yeah. And so this is how William is able simultaneously to fight the Spanish and yet claim to be loyal to the king of Spain. And as you say, I think it reflects just how incredibly respectful of authority people in the 16th century are. And even William, who's been in open conflict with Philip and the Spanish for four years, still can't quite bring himself to acknowledge that he is a rebel. Because to be a rebel against an anointed king is the worst thing that you could possibly do. You know, that's a big difference between the age of the American Revolution or the French Revolution.
只是这些腐败和邪恶的顾问。是的。这就是威廉能够同时与西班牙人作战，却又声称效忠西班牙国王的原因。正如你所说，我认为这反映了16世纪的人们对权威是多么的尊重。即使是与腓力和西班牙人公开冲突了四年的威廉，仍然无法让自己承认他是一个叛军。因为反抗受膏的国王是你可能做的最糟糕的事情。你知道，这与美国革命或法国革命时代有很大不同。
Yeah. I think in the 16th century, it's kind of almost in the border zones of inconceivable that you could do what William is effectively doing. And this is what makes him a kind of perfect figurehead for this revolt, which likewise isn't in, I mean, it is a revolt, but it's kind of, it's not a showy revolt. So Simon Sharma in his brilliant book on this, The Embarrassment of Riches, if the Dutch finally espoused independence, they did so with the lowest possible profile. So there is no equivalent of the Declaration of Independence that you get in the American Revolution. It's done in a slightly kind of crapped, well, I suppose, taciturn way. I mean, that's why William the Silent is a kind of perfect leader for it. Yeah, you can see how there's a spectrum that comes from this to the Innocular War of the 1640s,
是的。我认为在16世纪，你所做的事情几乎处于不可想象的边缘。这就是为什么他成为这场起义的完美领袖，这场起义同样不是，我的意思是，它是一场起义，但它不是一场炫耀性的起义。所以西蒙·沙马在他关于此事的精彩著作《财富的尴尬》中写道，如果荷兰人最终支持独立，他们也是以最低调的方式进行的。所以没有美国革命中那种《独立宣言》的等价物。它是以一种稍微有点笨拙的、嗯，我想，沉默寡言的方式完成的。我的意思是，这就是为什么沉默者威廉是它的完美领袖。是的，你可以看到从这到1640年代的内战之间有一个光谱，
where you have people moving from basically saying, well, I'm still very much a monarchist or just happened to be fighting on the side of parliament. And then they move towards Charles as the man of blood. And then at the other extreme, you have the American Revolution where they're ideologically leaning into the idea of rebellion and casting off kings. And then you have the French Revolution where they chop the king's head off. So, yeah, you can absolutely see the line of descent. But at the beginning, in the 16th century, with the Dutch Revolt, there's a reticence about it, almost a sense of embarrassment. And it's that, I think, which makes the Vilhelmus the perfect anthem for this revolt.
在那里，人们从基本上说，好吧，我仍然是一个君主主义者，或者只是碰巧站在议会一边。然后他们转向查理作为血腥之人。而在另一个极端，你有美国革命，他们在意识形态上倾向于叛乱和抛弃国王的想法。然后你有法国革命，他们砍掉了国王的头。所以，是的，你绝对可以看到这种传承。但在开始时，在16世纪，荷兰起义中有一种克制，几乎是一种尴尬感。我认为正是这一点使得《威廉颂》成为这场起义的完美国歌。
Because, of course, as we've said, it's a rebel song which proclaims loyalty in its opening verse. to the very king whom the rebels are fighting. So that's why you have William in that fur saying, oh, I'm very loyal to the king of Spain. If we go to the website of the Dutch Royal Family, which obviously one of your favourites, Tom, love it.
因为，当然，正如我们所说，这是一首叛军歌曲，在第一节中宣称效忠。效忠于叛军正在与之战斗的国王。这就是为什么威廉在那首诗中说，哦，我非常忠于西班牙国王。如果我们去荷兰王室的网站，这显然是你最喜欢的网站之一，汤姆，我喜欢它。
The website of the Dutch Royal Family says this song originated during the siege of the French city of Chartres in 1568. That's quite odd because that's further back and it's also in the wrong country. So how does it? Does this anthem written about siege in France before the high points of the Dutch Revolt
荷兰王室的网站说这首歌起源于1568年法国城市沙特尔的围城战。这很奇怪，因为那是更早的时候，而且是在错误的国家。所以它是怎么？这首关于法国围城战的国歌，在荷兰起义的高潮之前，
come to be the sort of the musical emblem of the Dutch Revolt? And what makes it even weirder is that it's about a Catholic garrison beating off a Protestant attack. So the song is originally anti-Protestant. And of course the rebels who compose the Wilhelmus are Protestant, are Calvinist. And I think there are two possible answers to this that perhaps are only seemingly contradictory. So the first is it's something that we've been talking about a lot in this series, that it's a gesture of appropriation. So it's a bit like the sea beggars sailing into Brill and appropriating all the Catholic churches and making them Calvinist, or the way in which the Hanoverians in 1745 appropriate the Jacobite melody that becomes God Save the King.
成为了荷兰起义的音乐象征？更奇怪的是，它是关于天主教驻军击退新教徒的进攻。所以这首歌最初是反新教的。当然，创作《威廉颂》的叛军是新教徒，是加尔文派。我认为对此有两个可能的答案，也许它们只是表面上矛盾的。首先，这是我们在本系列中一直在谈论的事情，这是一种挪用的姿态。所以这有点像海上乞丐驶入布里尔并挪用所有天主教堂并将它们变成加尔文派，或者汉诺威王朝在1745年挪用雅各布派旋律成为《天佑国王》的方式。
And those kind of elements of that in, with with the German national anthem as well, wasn't there? I mean, it's something that happens quite a lot. Tunes and indeed lyrics have multiple meanings, and you can seize them and turn them to your own ends. Yeah, and this is a kind of foreshadowing of what will happen in what emerges as the Dutch Republic, because in that, Calvinism will be enshrined as the public religion, the only one permitted to hold public services,
德国国歌中也有类似的元素，不是吗？我的意思是，这经常发生。曲调和歌词确实有多种含义，你可以抓住它们并把它们转向你自己的目的。是的，这是荷兰共和国出现后将发生的事情的预兆，因为在那个共和国中，加尔文主义将被奉为公共宗教，是唯一被允许举行公共礼拜的宗教，
and by and large of these public services being held in churches and chapels that previously had been Catholic. And so in a sense, the Wilhelmus is replicating that, in the form of song. Oh, isn't that nice? However, there are multiple ways of interpreting this. So that would appeal to the Calvinists in Williams' ranks. But you could also see it as being a gesture of accommodation to those who are not hardcore
总的来说，这些公共礼拜是在以前是天主教的教堂和礼拜堂举行的。所以从某种意义上说，威廉颂是以歌曲的形式复制了这一点。哦，那不是很好吗？然而，解释这一点有多种方式。所以这会吸引威廉队伍中的加尔文派。但你也可以把它看作是对那些不是铁杆加尔文派的人的一种妥协姿态，
Calvinists, because it's a Protestant song with a Catholic melody. I mean, that's how you could frame it. It's maybe a kind of compromise. And certainly that tells you something important about William himself and about many of the people who are rallying to his banner, because most of them are actually not hardcore Calvinists. And you've been saying all along, well, remember that William is a Catholic. William only converts to Calvinism in 1573. So that is after the Wilhelmus has actually been written. And William's own ambition for this new Dutch state, which he's trying to create,
因为这是一首带有天主教旋律的新教歌曲。我的意思是，你可以这样构思它。这可能是一种妥协。当然，这告诉你关于威廉本人以及许多聚集在他旗帜下的人的一些重要信息，因为他们中的大多数人实际上并不是铁杆加尔文派。你一直说，好吧，记住威廉是天主教徒。威廉直到1573年才皈依加尔文主义。所以那是在《威廉颂》实际写成之后。威廉本人对他试图创造的这个新荷兰国家的目标，
is that it should allow freedom of religion too, and I quote William here, reformed and Roman Catholic in public or in private, in church or in chapel. And ultimately, as we've said, this isn't how it works out. Calvinism does become kind of enshrined as the public religion in the Dutch revolt. But that commitment to freedom of religion, which William was so strongly identified with, I think for that reason it does remain a very important ideal for many people in the Dutch Republic, even so. And in the 17th century, there are all kinds of legal fictions that can be woven. They're all kinds of blind eyes that can be turned to Catholics, say, or Quakers or Jews or Muslims, practicing their own forms of religion.
是它应该允许宗教自由，我引用威廉的话，改革宗和罗马天主教在公共或私人场合，在教堂或礼拜堂。最终，正如我们所说，事情并非如此。加尔文主义确实在荷兰起义中被奉为公共宗教。但那种对宗教自由的承诺，威廉与此有着强烈的认同，我认为出于这个原因，它对荷兰共和国的许多人来说仍然是一个非常重要的理想。在17世纪，有各种各样的法律虚构可以编织。有各种各样对天主教徒、贵格会教徒、犹太人或穆斯林实践他们自己的宗教形式视而不见的情况。
And they, by and large, can do this without harassment. People are not kind of poking their noses in. It's not like Elizabethan England where, you know, priest hunters are out looking for Jesuits or anything like that. And in fact, Amsterdam will become one of the great centres of Jewish life in the 17th century. You know, it will become the home of Spinoza. who isn't only Jewish until he gets excommunicated by the synagogue in Amsterdam, but will become one of the great precursors of the radical enlightenment that comes to question the very value of religion itself.
他们大体上可以在没有骚扰的情况下做到这一点。人们不会像伊丽莎白时代的英国那样，你知道，猎巫人到处寻找耶稣会士之类的。事实上，阿姆斯特丹在17世纪将成为犹太生活的主要中心之一。你知道，它将成为斯宾诺莎的家。他不仅是犹太人，直到他被阿姆斯特丹的犹太会堂逐出教门，但他将成为激进启蒙运动的伟大先驱之一，开始质疑宗教本身的价值。
And so maybe in the Wilhelmus, the fact that you have this fusion of the Catholic and the Protestant, it's looking ahead to the kind of post-Reformation state that will kind of, you know, is being incubated in the Dutch Republic, perhaps, I don't know. But this is not uniquely a Dutch thing, though, actually, this thing about anthems being compromises and expressing paradoxes and so on, because it's actually not, you know, remember how the Weimar Republic adopted the German anthem in 1922, is a kind of compromise between conservatives and social democrats,
所以也许在《威廉颂》中，你拥有这种天主教和新教的融合，它展望了后宗教改革国家，它正在荷兰共和国中孵化，也许，我不知道。但这并不是荷兰独有的，关于国歌是妥协并表达悖论等，因为实际上不是，你知道，记住魏玛共和国在1922年是如何采用德国国歌的，作为保守派和社会民主党之间的一种妥协，
and this is not dissimilar. There's something for everybody in the anthem, isn't that? Yeah, and that's people tend to see in anthems what they want to see, I think. And so the more flexibility that's built in. to an anthem, in a sense, the more useful it can be, particularly if it's an emergent state. And William himself, as we've been describing throughout this episode, kind of like this emergent state is himself a figure of paradox. And so that's why I think it's, you know, so appropriate that the Dutch national anthem today is named after him. Because in all kinds of
这并不不同。国歌里有适合每个人的东西，不是吗？是的，人们倾向于在国歌中看到他们想看到的东西，我认为。所以内置的灵活性越多。对国歌来说，从某种意义上说，它就越有用，特别是如果它是一个新兴国家。而威廉本人，正如我们在本集节目中一直描述的那样，就像这个新兴国家一样，他本人就是一个悖论人物。这就是为什么我认为，你知道，荷兰国歌今天以他的名字命名是如此恰当。因为在各种
ways, he's a most improbable figure to be the Dutch, George Washington. So to go through the list of why he is not obviously a rebel. leader against the King of Spain. He is officially a servant of the King of Spain. He is a Stadtholder appointed by Philip. He is an aristocrat. He's the Prince of Orange. He's been born a German rather than Dutch. So it's improbable, I think, that he of all men would have emerged as the kind of founding father of what becomes a very Calvinist, very anti-Spanish, a very bourgeois republic in the 17th century. But I think William becomes loved by the Dutch. not kind of despite the long journey that he's made over the course of his life,
方面，他都是最不可能成为荷兰乔治·华盛顿的人物。所以列举一下为什么他显然不是一个反抗西班牙国王的叛军领袖。他正式是西班牙国王的仆人。他是腓力任命的总督。他是贵族。他是奥兰治亲王。他出生时是德国人而不是荷兰人。所以我认为，他竟然成为了17世纪一个非常加尔文派、非常反西班牙、非常资产阶级的共和国的国父，这是不可思议的。但我认为威廉被荷兰人所爱。不是尽管他一生中经历了漫长的旅程，
but because of it, they know what he's had to give up. They know the degree to which he's been on a journey, Dominion. Can I just ask one quick question before we move on? Why did he go on that journey? Because if it wasn't religious zeal that was powering him to give all these things up, to go through all these trials and tribulations, what is it that made him embrace the cause of revolt when he could have probably had a much nicer life,
而是因为这段旅程，多米尼克。在我继续之前，我能问一个简短的问题吗？他为什么要踏上那段旅程？因为如果不是宗教狂热驱使他放弃所有这些东西，经历所有这些磨难，是什么让他拥抱起义事业，而他本可以过上更好的生活，
if he bent the need to have her at the second and said, yeah, fine, crack on. I mean, it's a great question. And I think the answer is essentially that he, although he is not a committed Calvinist or indeed Catholic or maybe because of it, he has his own distinctive sense of what is right and wrong. And he feels that Philip is offending against that. And also, I think because even though he is of German origin, he has spent most of his childhood and youth and adulthood in the low countries.
如果他向腓力二世屈膝并说，好吧，没问题，继续吧。我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题。我认为答案本质上是，虽然他不是一个坚定的加尔文派或天主教徒，或者也许正因为如此，他有自己独特的对错感。他觉得腓力正在触犯这一点。而且，我认为因为尽管他是德国血统，但他大部分的童年、青年和成年时期都在低地国家度过。
and I think he has come to identify with the Dutch. I think he feels it's his kind of God-given duty. And ultimately, he ends up a martyr to that sense of duty because on the 10th of July 1584, he was assassinated in Delft, which is a very small provincial town. You know, the great Prince of Orange has been reduced to a kind of bourgeois house in Delft.
我认为他已经开始认同荷兰人了。我认为他觉得这是他上帝赋予的职责。最终，他成为了这种职责感的殉道者，因为在1584年7月10日，他在代尔夫特被暗杀，那是一个非常小的省城。你知道，伟大的奥兰治亲王被贬到了代尔夫特的一所资产阶级房子里。
And he's cornered there by a Catholic assassin called Balthazar Gerard. and Gerard kills William of Orange because he sees him as a traitor both to the King of Spain and to Catholicism. And, you know, if there's no question that Gerard is right, I mean, William had become a traitor to both Philip and to Catholicism. So in 1577, the Spanish governor of the low country had warned Philip, Orange, so William, hates nothing more in this world than your majesty, and if he could drink your blood he would do it. So Philip is alarmed by this and so in 1580 he'd placed a bounty on William's
他在那里被一个叫巴尔塔萨·杰拉德的天主教刺客逼入绝境。杰拉德杀死了奥兰治亲王威廉，因为他认为他是西班牙国王和天主教的叛徒。而且，你知道，毫无疑问杰拉德是对的，我的意思是，威廉确实成了腓力和天主教的叛徒。所以1577年，低地国家的西班牙总督曾警告腓力，奥兰治，也就是威廉，在这个世界上最恨的就是陛下，如果他能喝你的血，他会做的。所以腓力对此感到震惊，于是1580年他悬赏威廉的
head and this is part of what inspires Gerard to assassinate William. It's kind of offer of financial goodies. And William responds to this in turn. It's kind of very like tennis, tit for tat. He responds by writing an apology in which he accuses Philip of tyranny, of subverting the traditional liberties of the Dutch and just for good measure of having poisoned both his wife and his wife and his son. And then the following July, the rebels, led by William, take the key step, the key ideological leap into the future that will lead us to the English Civil War and to the American Revolution and to the French Revolution, when they issue an act of abjuration, which repudiates Philip II personally and all his heirs in perpetuity. And from that point on,
人头，这就是激励杰拉德暗杀威廉的部分原因。这是一种经济奖励。威廉反过来回应了这一点。这有点像网球，针锋相对。他通过写一份道歉书来回应，在书中他指责腓力暴政，颠覆了荷兰的传统自由，并顺便指责他毒死了他的妻子和儿子。第二年七月，以威廉为首的叛军采取了关键步骤，迈出了通往英国革命、美国革命和法国革命的未来关键意识形态飞跃，他们发布了一份《废黜法案》，个人否认了腓力二世及其所有继承人的永久权利。从那时起，
Philip's head is removed from coins from official seals, his coat of arms, is. taken down from public buildings. It's scrubbed from documents. And the pattern there, I'm sure, will be very familiar to our American listeners, the process by which previously loyal British subjects end up turning against George III and branding him a tyrant. Yeah. And so even though William doesn't get to see the proclamation of the Dutch Republic, he goes
腓力的头像从硬币、官方印章上被移除，他的纹章从公共建筑上被取下。它从文件中被擦除。那里的模式，我相信我们的美国听众会非常熟悉，即以前忠诚的英国臣民最终反抗乔治三世并称他为暴君的过程。是的。所以即使威廉没有看到荷兰共和国的宣告，他还是
down in history as its founding father. Yeah. So in the Vilhelmus, he's described as David. there's also a massively strong suggestion that he is Moses. So Moses, you know, the great Israelite leader who had led his people from out of bondage in Egypt across the Red Sea, so across kind of bogs and marshes and waterways in which he had destroyed the armies of Pharaoh, aka Philip II. But then Moses dies before reaching the promised land, just as William dies before the proclamation of what will become the Dutch Republic in 58.
作为其国父载入史册。是的。所以在《威廉颂》中，他被描述为大卫。还有一个非常强烈的暗示，他是摩西。所以摩西，你知道，伟大的以色列领袖，他带领他的人民走出埃及的束缚，穿过红海，穿过他摧毁了法老（即腓力二世）军队的沼泽和水道。但摩西在到达应许之地之前就去世了，就像威廉在58年荷兰共和国宣告之前就去世了一样。
And I think this is why throughout the Dutch Republic, the Vilhelmus retains its popularity. It's deployed it as a marching song when going to war against the Spanish, which continues for decades into the 17th century, as a battle anthem in wars against the English and the Portuguese. And I think just as a kind of reminder to the Dutch of what their liberty and all their incredible prosperity had cost them, that they had really, really had to fight for it. And so they owed William the man who had made it possible. complicated thing about it is that it's an anthem celebrating the birth of a republic, but Holland is not a republic? The Netherlands is the kingdom of the Netherlands.
我认为这就是为什么在整个荷兰共和国，《威廉颂》一直保持着它的受欢迎程度。它被用作对西班牙人作战时的行军歌曲，这种战争持续了17世纪的几十年，作为与英国人和葡萄牙人战争中的战斗国歌。我认为这只是作为一种提醒，提醒荷兰人他们的自由和所有令人难以置信的繁荣付出了什么代价，他们真的真的必须为之奋斗。所以他们欠威廉，那个使这一切成为可能的人。关于它的一件复杂的事情是，它是一首庆祝共和国诞生的国歌，但荷兰不是一个共和国？荷兰是荷兰王国。
Today it is, yeah. Yeah, so what happens there? Is it just so protean that it can be reinterpreted as the Netherlands goes through these kind of constitutional evolutions? Well, Dominic, we're in the process at the moment of preparing a series of episodes on the founding fathers of America for the anniversary of the Declaration of Independence. And one of those founding fathers, Thomas Jefferson, was haunted by the anxiety that the office of the president of the United States might mutate and become something hereditary, might ultimately evolve into something overtly monarchical. And one of the reasons he fears that is that he is aware what happened
今天是，是的。是的，那么那里发生了什么？它是否如此多变，以至于随着荷兰经历这些宪法演变，它可以被重新解释？好吧，多米尼克，我们目前正在准备一系列关于美国国父的剧集，以纪念《独立宣言》周年。其中一位国父，托马斯·杰斐逊，被一种焦虑所困扰，即美国总统的职位可能会变异并成为某种世袭的东西，最终可能会演变成某种公开的君主制。他担心这一点的原因之一是他意识到发生了什么
in the Dutch Republic, where the heirs of William the Silent held his office of Stadtholder as a kind of hereditary office. So in Holland, Every Stadtholder without exception was a member of William's dynasty. And the most famous of these literally ends up a king. And this is the guy who, the Prince of Orange, who becomes William III of England, of Scotland, and of course of Ireland. Yeah, hence Orange Men, because he defeats James II at the Battle of the Boyne in 1690s, the Orange Men, the Orange Order in Northern Ireland. And eventually in the middle of the 18th century, the Dutch just say, well, let's drop the pretense.
在荷兰共和国，威廉·沉默者的继承人以一种世袭职位的形式担任执政官。因此在荷兰，每一位执政官无一例外都是威廉王朝的成员。其中最著名的一位最终成为了国王，也就是那位奥兰治亲王，他后来成为了英国、苏格兰以及爱尔兰的威廉三世。没错，这就是“奥兰治人”的由来，因为他在17世纪90年代的博因河战役中击败了詹姆斯二世，从而有了北爱尔兰的“奥兰治人”和“奥兰治令”。最终在18世纪中叶，荷兰人决定不再掩饰了。
Let's just turn the Stadtholder into a king, don't they? Yeah, a bit like the Romans saying, oh, well, you know, let's not pretend. Obviously, Caesar is now our lord and master. It's the same thing. And it's exactly the kind of the model that so alarms the founding fathers that something like this could happen. And the consequence of this is, you know, there are still Republicans in what had been the Dutch Republic. And these Republicans come to see the Vilhelmus as a kind of polarizing song rather than as it had previously been a unifying one. What had been a kind of independent Dutch state under the conquest of the French Revolutionary armies, it becomes a Batavian Republic.
他们直接把执政官变成了国王，不是吗？是的，这有点像罗马人说，哦，好吧，我们别再假装了，显然凯撒现在就是我们的主宰。这完全是一回事。这正是让美国开国元勋们感到惊恐的模式，担心类似的事情会发生。其结果是，在曾经的荷兰共和国里依然存在共和派。这些共和派开始将《威廉颂》视为一首具有分裂色彩的歌曲，而不是像以前那样作为一首团结之歌。曾经作为一个独立的荷兰国家，在被法国革命军征服后，它变成了巴达维亚共和国。
And then it comes a kind of kingdom under one of Napoleon's brothers. And in that period, the Vilhelmus is officially banned. And I think even after Napoleon is overthrown and the Dutch get their independence back, the Wilhelmus kind of retains the quality of the taboo. It is kind of associated with a form of rule that they feel a bit embarrassed about. And this is despite the fact that actually the House of Orange Nassau, so the descendants of William the Silent, have by this point returned to the Netherlands from exile and have actually officially proclaimed themselves monarchs, which they had not previously done. So from 1815, the heirs of William the Silent rule as kings or as subsequently happens as queens. But because the scars of the revolution are so fresh, you know, they don't want to tempt fate by saying, well, we will have the Vilhelmus as our anthem. You know, they want to have something that is acceptable to all their subjects, including Republicans, including people who are resentful of their dynasty.
后来它在拿破仑的一个兄弟统治下变成了一个王国。在那段时期，《威廉颂》被正式禁止。我认为即使在拿破仑被推翻、荷兰恢复独立后，《威廉颂》依然保留了一种禁忌的色彩。它与一种让他们感到尴尬的统治形式联系在一起。尽管事实上，奥兰治-拿骚家族，也就是威廉·沉默者的后裔，此时已经从流亡中回到荷兰，并正式宣布自己为君主，这是他们之前没有做过的。因此从1815年起，威廉·沉默者的继承人以国王或后来的女王身份进行统治。但由于革命的创伤太深，他们不想通过将《威廉颂》定为国歌来触霉头。他们想要一首能被所有臣民接受的歌曲，包括共和派和那些对王朝心怀不满的人。
And so this is kind of maps on to what you were describing about the, the search in Germany for a suitable anthem, an anthem that, you know, can tick all the boxes. And so they hold a competition to find an anthem that is less factional than the Vilhelmus. And the winning entry is one that everyone feels is splendid and is exactly what they need. And I will read the opening lines. Whoever has Dutch blood flowing in their veins free of foreign blemishes, whose heart glows for king and country, rejoice in song as we do. So what could possibly go wrong with that?
这与你所描述的德国寻找合适国歌的过程很像，一首能满足所有条件的国歌。于是他们举办了一场比赛，寻找一首比《威廉颂》更少派系色彩的歌曲。获胜的作品被大家认为非常精彩，正是他们所需要的。我来读一下开头的几行：凡是血管里流淌着荷兰血液、没有外国污点的人，凡是为国王和国家心潮澎湃的人，请像我们一样欢唱吧。那么，这首歌会有什么问题呢？
Holy unexceptional. No one can complain about that. I don't mind that. Although, of course, the problem is that line whose heart glows for king and country because what happens if you end up with a queen? That's a massive problem. And they do end up with a queen,
简直平庸至极。没人能抱怨这个。我不介意这一点。当然，问题在于“为国王和国家心潮澎湃”这一句，因为如果你最终迎来了一位女王怎么办？那是个大问题。而他们确实迎来了一位女王，
Wilhelmina, who becomes the new monarch in 1890 and she's a very young girl when she succeeds to the throne. So she's only inaugurated in 1898. And they sing this anthem, and it's, massive problem with the metrics of it. The metre is all over the place. And what about now? A lot of people may have raised an eyebrow out of the words foreign blemishes.
威廉明娜，她在1890年成为新君主，继位时还是个非常年轻的女孩。所以她直到1898年才举行就职典礼。他们唱了这首国歌，但它的韵律有很大的问题。节奏完全乱套了。那现在呢？很多人可能对“外国污点”这几个字皱起了眉头。
So I would guess in the, if they still had that anthem, well, if they had that anthem after about 1950, there would be issues, wouldn't they? In a continent, you know, transformed by immigration. Well, I think even before that, it's seen as awkward. It's seen as kind of inappropriate to the age. And particularly in the early 1930s, when, of course, the Dutch are very aware of what is going on in
所以我猜，如果他们还在使用那首国歌，或者说如果他们在1950年后还在使用它，那肯定会有问题，不是吗？在一个被移民改变的洲际大陆上。嗯，我认为在那之前它就被视为尴尬了。它被认为与那个时代不符。特别是在20世纪30年代初，当时荷兰人非常清楚在
Germany, the discussion of kind of pure blood and foreign blemishes comes to seem a little bit Nazi and the Dutch definitely want to distinguish themselves from the Nazis. And so in the early 1930s, 1932, to be precise, say one year before the Nazis come to power, she decrees that Bill Helmess should for the first time be officially inscribed as the Dutch national anthem. And this is despite the fact that it, you know, it's still pretty unpopular with Dutch Republicans. You know, it's seen as two royalists, two sectarian. But actually, when the Nazis invade the Netherlands and occupy it, the Vilhelmus comes into its own. It provides the Dutch with a kind of great rallying point, because all that stuff that you get in verse six, you know, the talk of defying tyranny, William's refusal to submit to the enemy, this becomes very moving to people in the Dutch resistance.
德国发生的事情，关于纯正血统和外国污点的讨论开始显得有点纳粹化，而荷兰人绝对想把自己与纳粹区分开来。因此在20世纪30年代初，确切地说是1932年，也就是纳粹上台前一年，她颁布法令，首次将《威廉颂》正式定为荷兰国歌。尽管它在荷兰共和派中仍然很不受欢迎。它被认为太保皇、太宗派了。但实际上，当纳粹入侵并占领荷兰时，《威廉颂》发挥了它的作用。它为荷兰人提供了一个伟大的集结号，因为你在第六节中看到的所有内容，关于反抗暴政、威廉拒绝向敌人屈服的描述，对荷兰抵抗运动的人来说变得非常感人。
And by the end of the war, even anti-monicists have taken it to their heart. I don't think there's any great debate now in the Netherlands that, you know, it should be removed. I mean, any Dutch listeners, if there is, let us know. But it seems pretty kind of bedded down. And so it's not the oldest national anthem, but it is the oldest song to have become a national anthem. Oh, and just one further footnote, the Japanese national anthem has as its lyrics, a poem from the 10th century. So that's the age of Lady Mirosaki and say, Shonigan. but the music is incredibly modern
到战争结束时，即使是反君主主义者也把它铭记在心。我不认为现在荷兰国内还有什么关于是否应该废除它的争论。我是说，如果有任何荷兰听众，请告诉我们。但它似乎已经根深蒂固了。所以它不是最古老的国歌，但它是成为国歌的最古老的歌曲。哦，还有一个脚注，日本国歌的歌词是一首10世纪的诗。那是紫式部和清少纳言的时代，但音乐是非常现代的
and the idea of using it is very modern. So the Vilhelmus definitely has that status as the oldest coherent song to be a national anthem. And it perfectly captures this doesn't it, the complexities of Dutch history. So you've got this bloke who's the founding father than Moses of the Dutch Republic who's actually, you know, it's a song about
使用它的想法也非常现代。所以《威廉颂》绝对拥有作为最古老连贯歌曲成为国歌的地位。它完美地捕捉到了这一点，不是吗？荷兰历史的复杂性。所以你有这样一个家伙，他是荷兰共和国的国父，是荷兰的摩西，而这实际上是一首关于
something that happened in France, who, you know, he's changed religion about six times, loyalty to the king of Spain, all that sort of stuff. I like that because it's kind of, I like an anthem that has a, a little bit of complexity, a little bit of ambiguity to it. And kind of perfectly channels, as you say, lots of the complexities that have characterised Dutch history
发生在法国的事情的歌，他改变了大约六次宗教信仰，对西班牙国王的忠诚等等。我喜欢这一点，因为它有一种，我喜欢一首带有一点复杂性、一点模糊性的国歌。它完美地传达了，正如你所说，许多塑造了荷兰历史的复杂性
in the 16th century and through the centuries that have followed. Well, fascinating story. Thank you very much, Tom. If you're interested in national anthems, generally, you can, of course, read the Restis History newsletter, which is going to have loads about national anthems and their history. So you can go to the Restis History website. Give us your email, and we'll send you the newsletter, which is completely free.
在16世纪以及随后的几个世纪里。嗯，引人入胜的故事。非常感谢你，汤姆。如果你对国歌感兴趣，通常情况下，你可以阅读《历史的其余部分》通讯，里面会有大量关于国歌及其历史的内容。所以你可以访问《历史的其余部分》网站。留下你的电子邮件，我们会把完全免费的通讯发送给你。
if you want to hear next week's episodes which are absolutely fascinating stories about Brazil and South Africa you can hear them right now if you're a member of the Restis History Club and if you're not a member of the club and you want to have all the amazing supplementary benefits then head to theresteshistory.com to sign up.
如果你想收听下周关于巴西和南非的绝对精彩的故事，如果你是《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的会员，你现在就可以收听。如果你还不是俱乐部会员，想要获得所有惊人的补充福利，请前往 theresteshistory.com 注册。
I'll see you next time for Brazil and South Africa and we will of course leave you with the Dutch National Anthem. Bye bye. Bye bye. Hello everybody. Now, as those of you who are good children will know, here in Britain, on the 21st of June, it's Father's Day. But not just here in Britain. It's also Father's Day on 21st of June in the United States, in Canada and in the Republic of Ireland. So those are four countries that are united by dads who love to listen to the rest is history.
下次关于巴西和南非的节目再见，当然，我们将以荷兰国歌结束。再见。再见。大家好。现在，正如你们这些好孩子所知道的，在英国，6月21日是父亲节。但不仅仅是在英国。在美国、加拿大和爱尔兰共和国，6月21日也是父亲节。所以这四个国家因为那些喜欢收听《历史的其余部分》的爸爸们而团结在一起。
And that is why we are offering an amazing 25. percent Father's Day discount on the subscription price to the rest is history club because we are all heart. So treat the Peter the Great in your own life this Father's Day to early access to full series. You get early access, that you get that with a membership. You get bonus episodes. You get ad-free listening. You get access to tickets for live shows. Basically, you get an entire host of supplementary benefits.
这就是为什么我们为《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的订阅价格提供惊人的25%父亲节折扣，因为我们全心全意。所以这个父亲节，用提前访问完整系列来款待你生命中的彼得大帝吧。你获得提前访问权，会员资格就包含这些。你获得额外剧集。你获得无广告收听。你获得现场演出门票的购买权。基本上，你获得了一整套补充福利。
And that, I think, is what a lot of patriarchs want, isn't it? It absolutely is because I think nothing says happy Father's Day quite like the chance to listen to six solid hours, ad free about the First World War. Yeah, that's what most fathers want. So head to the rest ishistory.com and click on the word gifts. And that gift, membership of our much-loved Restis History Club, will land straight in your father's inbox on Father's Day itself. So if you want to give the best Father's Day gift there's ever been in history, ever, and we say this as the presenters of the Restis History, you know what to do. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而我认为，这正是许多家长想要的，不是吗？绝对是，因为我认为没有什么比有机会连续六小时无广告收听关于第一次世界大战的内容更能代表父亲节快乐了。是的，这就是大多数父亲想要的。所以前往 theresteshistory.com 并点击“礼物”一词。那份礼物，也就是我们备受喜爱的《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的会员资格，将在父亲节当天直接发送到你父亲的收件箱中。所以如果你想送出有史以来最好的父亲节礼物，我们作为《历史的其余部分》的主持人，你知道该怎么做。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。